hallo leute wir haben heute besuch aus
schweben und wir stellen euch heute
deutsche redewendungen wortwörtlich vor
zwei fliegen mit einer klappe schlagen
wenn man zwei fliegen mit einer klappe
schlägt dann hat man glück gehabt denn
durch einen günstigen umstand konnte man
zwei dinge die man erledigen wollte auf
einmal erledigen
dieses sprichwort überträgt sich auf
alle zusammenhänge wo man etwas
erreichen oder erledigen möchte mit dem
falschen fuß ausstehen wenn jemand
schlecht drauf ist oder einfach nur pech
hat den ganzen tag dann sagen wir über
diese person dass er heute morgen
wahrscheinlich mit dem falschen fuß
aufgestanden ist
das gibt es heute es gibt genug es gibt
dicke luft wurde früher wörtlich benutzt
und zwar schon seit dem 16 jahrhundert
es meint dass die luft nicht sauber ist
zum beispiel ist sie vielleicht dreckig
mit schadstoffen oder auf dem
schlachtfeld gab es auch oft eine
schlechte luft
heute benutzt man dieses sprichwort vor
allem dann wenn man eine schlechte
stimmung oder eine schlechte atmosphäre
ausdrücken möchte zum beispiel kann man
sagen im weißen haus gibt es dicke luft
das heißt es gibt eine unangenehme
stimmung zwischen den menschen oder eine
schlechte atmosphäre
das handtuch werfen das handtuch werfen
diese redewendung kommt aus dem boxsport
vielleicht habt ihr das schon mal
gesehen zwei menschen boxen und der
trainer wirft das handtuch in den ring
wenn der trainer das macht heißt das
dass der trainer dem kampf beendet und
das er für seinen sportler aus gibt das
handtuch werfen benutzt man mittlerweile
auch in anderen zusammenhängen
wenn jemand das handtuch wirft heißt das
dass er aufgibt es gibt zb einen streit
oder etwas und jemand gibt auf dann sagt
man auch er hat das handtuch geworfen
[Musik]
eine hand wäscht die andere
diesen spruch haben schon die römer auf
latein benutzt und noch heute gibt es
dieses sprichwort es drückt eine gewisse
erwartungshaltung aus und es bedeutet
wenn man etwas für eine andere person
macht dann wird diese person der anderen
person etwas zurückgeben wenn ich also
sage eine hand wäscht die andere
dann heißt das ich habe etwas für dich
gemacht aber beim nächsten mal wirst du
etwas für mich machen alles in butter
das sprichwort alles in butter heißt
alles ist okay das für unser video für
heute wenn ihr ein deutschlehrer seit
oder eine deutschlehrerin und ihr kommt
mit ihrer schulklasse auch mal nach
berlin und möchtet uns treffen und mit
uns einen passenden drehen dann schreibt
uns gerne eine e mail oder post einen
kommentar und wenn er ideen habt ihr
weitere themen schreibt uns unbedingt
auch jetzt könnt ihr sie german noch
unterstützen das geht bei tätscheln
darüber freuen wir uns sehr und ihr
könnt natürlich wieder die german
abonnieren
dankeschön fürs zu sehen und das nächste
woche